at the end of Creek
um everyone was allowed to take an
outfit because all the outfits were very
expensive designer Brands and I was like
um
my outfits are like I brought from home
they're they're literally mine so I
don't think this is fair at all right
um so I took the giant stag painting
behind Stevie's desk really yes I also
took I did this that's the beginning
um I took um oh well these are all my
things these are all my things this is
my Stevie name tag oh my gosh TV name
tag this is
this is this is my keychain it's this
this is to the Roses um room in the
motel oh God
I'm so sorry these are all my things I
love it we just went into your place and
stole them so okay so you're okay with
stealing from my place yes exactly